bonjour les hommes roses vivent à nouveau
précisément qui a la gorge tranchée
hors de cet ordre mondial mendel est le
meilleur bien de retour au travail je vois ce qui se passe
oui moi et les garçons en avons parlé nous
pensons que vous êtes vraiment hétéro eh bien
je n'ai jamais  été accusé de cela auparavant
mais j'apprécie le sentiment que tu es l'
un de nous maintenant quelle belle chose à dire
merci cher pinky merci tu dois
te remercier loup rien d'autre dis lui
pas comme le point de contrôle 19 n'est pas un
hoosegow à deux bits  vous avez des barres de fer de gros calibre
sur chaque fenêtre de ventilation de porte vous avez 72
gardes au sol à 60 de plus dans deux
tours vous avez une chute de 325 pieds dans un
fossé plein de crocodiles mais comme le
meilleur de tous, il a un point faible qui
dans  il se trouve que cette affaire prend la forme d'
un système d'égout pluvial prend du temps une
division de fortification rocheuse
au Moyen Âge maintenant personne ne dit que c'est
une promenade sur une promenade bordée d'arbres
avec la belle dame au portail blanc
mais il a ce que vous  appellerais
vulnérabilité un  d c'est notre
beurre bettin creuse un coup
d'oeil toi
toi